je suis pas fan de ce genre de démarche
parce que il ya un contexte français
il ya une communauté musulmane en france
qui est majoritairement dans une
démarche d'essayer de vivre sereinement
en france après bien sûr on sait qu'il
ya des problèmes il ya des attentats il
ya des malentendus il ya des
incompréhensions et à des tensions qui
sont grandissantes et moi je suis
partisan de ceux qui essayent plutôt de
désamorcer la situation le dialogue et
qui essaie de ramener un petit peu de
sérénité
nous appelons bien sûr à défendre les
intérêts de notre pays est face aux
appels au boycott contre les produits
français
nous appelons les musulmans de france à
être très vigilants et aarau a dénoncé
ce type d'appel qui tentent de diviser
notre société est de séparer les
citoyens de confession musulmane de
leurs concitoyens